supreme court where hundreds of
protesters gathered last night after the
stunning leak of what is reportedly a
draft opinion suggesting the court will
strike down roe v wade this summer many
experts have predicted the court will
roll back abortion rights after
conservatives gained a six to three
majority on the court it's a strongly
worded draft opinion signed by justice
samuel alito and obtained by politico
the supreme court has not confirmed the
authenticity of the document and we must
point out a lot can change before a
final ruling is issued for more on all
of it let's go to jan crawford she's
outside the supreme court jan this would
be an astonishing leak and a landmark
decision good morning to you good
morning tony and you're exactly right an
unprecedented leap from the supreme
court something that didn't even happen
when the presidency was on the line in
bush versus score and in the states uh
the implications for an overturning of
roe versus weight are massive many of
them those states already have been
preparing for that
[Applause]
the news set off late night protests
from both sides of the supreme court
america doesn't want to overturn roe v
wade that there is support to maintain
it the reversal of roverson is good it
will save lives and that is good and
they should keep going forward with the
majority opinion the leaked supreme
court draft opinion shows the
conservative majority voted to strike
down roe versus wade the 1973 landmark
decision guaranteeing abortion rights
the 98-page draft opinion from february
was obtained by politico from a person
familiar with the court's proceedings in
a mississippi law banning abortion after
15 weeks
writing for the majority justice samuel
alito wrote roe was egregiously wrong
from the start it is time to heed the
constitution and return the issue of
abortion to the people's elected
representatives four other conservative
justices reportedly also had voted to
overturn roe in the mississippi case
it's unclear whether chief justice john
roberts would have allowed the
mississippi lot to stand without
overturning roe or whether he joined the
liberals also unclear whether the early
draft opinion will become the final
decision sending the issue of abortion
back to the states
[Applause]
right now 13 states have laws banning
all or nearly all abortions that would
be triggered if roe were overturned the
ceo of planned parenthood said abortion
is currently still legal and we will
continue to fight like hell to protect
the right to access safe legal abortion
but the leak of a draft opinion sent
shock waves throughout the legal
community and beyond this has never
happened before
it's a tremendously big deal for the
court and its significance for the
court's legitimacy is impossible to
overstate jeff rosen is the president
and ceo of the national constitution
center
the court takes its
secrecy incredibly seriously the
justices will investigate this leak
vigorously and try to find out who the
leaker was
now early drafts of decisions they often
change quite a bit and justices in the
past have actually switched their votes
it is unlikely that that's going to
happen in this case however a decision
is expected sooner rather than later
well before the end of the court's term
at the end of june tony
jan we just heard jeffrey rosen talk
about how unprecedented it is for a leak
like this to occur why might someone
leak this
you know tony leakers sometimes talk to
the press because they're outraged
they're disgruntled or perhaps in this
case they're trying to put pressure on
one of the justices that narrow five
justice majority to change their minds
this information this draft opinion is
so closely held inside the supreme court
that so few people would have access to
it it will be tremendous implications
inside this building the trust among
those justices possibly coming from a
law clerk
yeah and speaking of access we should
talk about the implications here jan
you've been to mississippi and other
states preparing for this decision if it
ends up being the ruling what are the
implications there
well it would mean that abortion access
depends on where women live so if you
live in mississippi you're going to have
to drive a long way to a state that
allows abortion rights and as i said
many of these states have already been
preparing for passing laws to prohibit
access to abortion while you see other
more liberal states passing laws
guaranteeing access this will all go now
to the states and their elected
officials if this decision holds
for nearly 50 years guaranteed as a
constitutional right access to abortion
could be no longer jan thank you very
much